[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 1er mars voici le programme
de ce soir le Salon international de
l'agriculture se tient toute cette
semaine jusqu'au 5 mars à Paris
l'opportunité pour les agriculteurs Yves
Linois de faire découvrir leur
savoir-faire et leurs produits à
l'occasion de journalistes de la
rédaction se sont rendus sur place ils
se sont intéressés aux aides mises en
place pour soutenir les agriculteurs
yvelinois dans leur quotidien samedi
prochain c'est la journée mondiale de
l'obésité l'objectif sensibiliser sur
cette maladie qui touche 24 millions de
personnes en France soit environ un
Français sur deux l'obésité est
présentée comme le mal du 21e siècle
alors comment y faire face nous en
parlerons avec Claudine canalet
présidente de l'association poids plumes
France qui accompagne les personnes en
situation d'obésité et Angélique Lafont
cadre de santé à l'hôpital de
Rambouillet et enfin en direction le zoo
safari de Thoiry dans votre 7 8 le parc
se métamorphose et investi 30 millions
d'euros d'ici 2028 pour réaliser des
travaux d'ampleur les premiers résultats
seront visibles dès cette année en
septembre 5 lots vont sortir de vont
sortir de terre pour pouvoir dormir au
plus près des éléphants notre
journaliste Mickael el midoro s'est
entretenu avec la PDG du groupe Touareg
Christelle berchenille les détails dans
cette émission et en plateau de
journalistes de la rédaction de TV 78
régénera la chez Céline Charles bonsoir
bonsoir alors Céline comme d'habitude le
mercredi vous allez nous parler des
films à ne pas manquer cette semaine
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
petit teasing alors comme d'habitude
trois films alors déjà le nouvel opus
d'une saga célèbre un drame de Sam
Mendes et une comédie française et donc
ce sera enfin d'émission restez bien
avec nous Régine vous dans le cadre des
vœux d'orientation sur la plateforme qui
se termine le jeudi 9 mars je le
rappelle vous venez nous parler d'une
école du territoire dans les Yvelines de
quoi de quelle école vous allez nous
parler ce soir il en a-t-il de ce soir
je vais vous parler du CFM BTP c'est le
centre de formation des métiers des
travaux publics et du bâtiment et c'est
basé à Trappes donc on en parlera plus
en détail tout à l'heure pour en parler
nous sommes aussi avec un étudiant du
centre de formation des métiers du
bâtiment des travaux publics Julien
Guillaume bonsoir bonsoir alors pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez choisi de vous
orienter vers cette école
parce que c'était une école qui était
déjà proximité de mon domicile et puis
qui proposait un nombre de formations
qui est très varié avec un cursus
pouvant aller du Cap jusqu'aux BTS donc
c'était des vraiment une orientation qui
qui me plaisait dans le bâtiment dans le
bâtiment
on en parlera plus en détail tout à
l'heure je le rappelle les lycéens et
les étudiants qui souhaitent se
réorienter ont jusqu'au jeudi 9 mars
pour rentrer leurs vœux sur la
plateforme parcoursup avec nous
également un plateau Claudine canalet
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes la
présidente de l'association Les pois
plumes France votre association
somobilise à l'occasion de la Journée
mondiale de l'obésité c'est ce samedi le
samedi 4 mars à travers cette
association vous accompagnez les
personnes en situation d'obésité alors
comment est-ce que vous les accompagnez
on accompagne il suffit effectivement
ces personnes dans leur parcours puisque
on crée des échanges entre pairs de
façon à les sécuriser à les sensibiliser
à les rassurer aussi et à les aider dans
leur choix puisque on verra par la suite
on vous expliquera un peu plus dans
longueur il y a différentes façons de
soigner cette obésité et ensuite on crée
effectivement aussi des actions comme
samedi prochain de prévention et
d'information auprès des grands publics
et de tous les médias pour effectivement
ma sensibiliser pour rappeler que
l'obésité c'est une maladie et qu'on en
guérit pas malheureusement oui vous avez
plusieurs rendez-vous au programme dans
4 centres
spécialisés dans la prise en charge de
l'obésité dont l'hôpital de Rambouillet
on en parlera tout à l'heure on en
parlera dans le détail puisque il y a
beaucoup de choses au programme et je
pense que cette journée sera très
alléchante voilà beaucoup de choses
également dans le 7 8 de ce soir mais
juste avant de s'y plonger je vous
propose de regarder la météo de demain
demain matin le soleil sera encore au
rendez-vous sur l'ensemble des Yvelines
au niveau des températures il fera
toujours très froid comptez 0° à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et
Rambouillet et moins 1° à Houdan alors
couvrez-vous bien dans l'après-midi le
ciel sera toujours bien dégagé avec un
beau soleil côté température comptez 8
degrés du côté de Houdan et Versailles
et 9 degrés dans les secteurs de
Mantes-la-Jolie et Rambouillet et demain
nous fêterons la sainte Charles Le Point
maintenant sur l'actualité dans les
Yvelines avec Julien Leroy
santé et prévention le cancer colorectal
touche chaque année plus de 43 000
personnes alors que le taux de
participation dépistage n'est que de 33%
face à ce constat la Ligue contre le
cancer renouvelle le mois de
sensibilisation mars bleu pris en charge
assez tôt ce type de cancer peut être
guéri dans 9 cas sur 10 si vous avez
entre 50 ans et 74 ans vous pouvez vous
faire livrer un kit de dépistage à
domicile gratuitement quatrième édition
pour l'opération aux arbres citoyens à
Poissy dès aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 30
avril les picia quai volontaire peuvent
s'inscrire pour obtenir gratuitement un
arbre à planter dans leur jardin une
trentaine de ses végétaux seront
distribués aux habitants après un tirage
au sort cette initiative s'inscrit dans
la campagne de revégétalisation de la
commune dont l'objectif est de planter
1000 arbres d'ici 2025 le club le
village version 2023 a rouvert ses
portes au public ce mercredi après trois
ans de travaux l'association l'Union
nationale des centres sportifs de gère
désormais la structure en délégation de
service public de nouvelles activités
font leur apparition comme le foot A5 ou
le paddle des tarifs découvertes seront
proposés aux usagers jusqu'au 2 avril
prochain une nouvelle expérience pour
les fans de jeux vidéo la seconde salle
de réalité virtuelle Eva des Yvelines
ouvre aujourd'hui au Mureaux jusqu'à 10
joueurs équipés d'un casque VR et d'une
arme connectée peuvent s'affronter au
sein d'une arène de 500 m² univers
futuriste mêlant action et stratégie ce
concept 100% français est présent dans
19 villes de France dont Maurepas une
légende s'est éteinte aujourd'hui
l'ancienne attaquant de l'équipe de
France de football juste fontaine et
décédé à l'âge de 89 ans recordman du
nombre de buts inscrits en Coupe du
monde avec 13 réalisations pendant le
Mondial 1958 il a aussi entraîné le
jeune club du Paris Saint-Germain dans
les Yvelines entre 1973 et 1976
permettant sa montée en première
division des 1974
[Musique]
au cœur de l'actualité également le
Salon International de l'Agriculture à
Paris qui se tient à cette semaine ils
sont une dizaine d'agriculteurs
yvelinois être présents sur place cette
année la région Île-de-France est le
département des Yvelines ont joué un
rôle primordial dans le développement de
leur activité réginera lait chez Patrick
Jacques de dixmutz se sont rendus sur
place pour connaître leur parcours
regardez
[Musique]
le Salon de l'Agriculture une belle
vitrine pour les agriculteurs chaque
année le département des Yvelines invite
plus d'une dizaine de producteurs du
territoire cette année ils étaient 10 à
se relayer sur le stand du département
c'est une chance énorme qu'on nous offre
même si on a 2 mètres carrés c'est et
c'est énorme on a été invité par le
département des Yvelines pour
représenter les producteurs yvelinois
l'avantage c'est qu'on puisse avoir une
belle vitrine au niveau du salon parmi
les enjeux majeurs du département
favoriser les initiatives locales et
développer les circuits courts une
collaboration a été mise en place avec
les Hauts-de-Seine pour favoriser la
consommation locale notamment dans les
collèges nous avons en commun d'essayer
de développer tout ce qui est
agroalimentaire et en particulier de
développer les circuits courts pour
permettre à nos collégiens que ce soit
dans le 92 78 d'accéder à des produits
qui étaient qui ont été cultivés dans le
département des idées autre acteur en
soutien aux agriculteurs l'Île-de-France
et l'Europe elles investissent chaque
année 20 millions d'euros pour les
agriculteurs franciliens on accompagne
les agriculteurs aussi bien sur
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
puisque c'est un enjeu essentiel le
renouvellement des générations on va
aider à la transmission des
exploitations et on est on aide aussi
les agriculteurs sur tout ce qui est
investissement donc c'est la
construction de hangar l'ouverture de
boutiques à la ferme et puis aussi
maintenant depuis quelques années l'aide
au changement climatique pour un projet
d'investissement si je prends par
exemple un investissement productif donc
par exemple un nouvel outil de
production qui permet de faire mieux des
biscuits de faire mieux des cookies on
peut avoir des aides qui sont comprises
entre 30 et 50% du financement donc
c'est non négligeable et c'est aussi une
forme de garantie pour les banques les
Yvelines abritent plus de 3000 emplois
directs dans le secteur agricole et
16000 emplois en direct dans le secteur
agroalimentaire
ce samedi 4 mars c'est la journée
mondiale de l'obésité en évènement pour
sensibiliser à cette maladie qui touche
de plus en plus de personnes en France
et dans le monde à cette occasion
l'association poids plumes France
organise des rendez-vous dans 4 centres
spécialisés dans la prise en charge de
l'obésité notamment à l'Institut
Mutualiste Montsouris de Paris et au
centre hospitalier de Rambouillet pour
en parler Claudine canalet présidente de
l'association poids plumes France et
Angélique Laffont cadre de santé au
centre hospitalier de Rambouillet
bonsoir alors près d'un Français sur
deux est touché par l'obésité et le
surpoids selon une récente étude de la
ligue contre l'obésité et l'Inserm alors
quel est l'objectif de cette journée
Claudine canalet est-ce que c'est
rappelé que l'obésité est avant tout une
maladie oui alors ça il faut vraiment le
marteler il faut que les gens prennent
conscience qu'en fait c'est pas le fait
de rester sur son canapé ou de manger
pas sain que on devient gros c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça la maladie
obésité effectivement ben c'est une
maladie multifactorielle et il faut
qu'elle soit vraiment prise en charge
très tôt pour effectivement essayer de
la contourner et alors comment se fait
dépister alors on va voir déjà son
médecin traitant il y a différents
centres on peut aller voir son médecin
traitant je pense que le médecin
traitant joue un rôle très important il
y a aussi les tous les services les CPTs
les CMS qui sont là aussi pour aider et
accompagner alors centre alors je me
rappelle plus CMS et centre médical de
santé et CPTs et je pense c'est une
plateforme qui oriente effectivement qui
est tout un réseau qui oriente les
personnes en situation d'obésité
d'accord
donc la journée est aussi très
importante donc c'est toujours le 4 mars
ça ne changera pas c'est une journée
mondiale c'est pour sensibiliser
effectivement la révélation au regard
des personnes qui sont en situation
d'obésité il y a différentes façons de
la prendre en charge et donc je on
accompagne ces passions aussi au sein de
au CHU de Rambouillet pour effectivement
prévenir et accompagner les personnes
qui désirent se faire prendre en charge
donc on parlera un petit peu plus tard
de cette série en charge par l'hôpital
de Rambouillet elle touche de plus en
plus de Français et aussi de plus en
plus de jeunes depuis
1997 l'obésité a été multipliée par 4
chez les 18 24 ans la situation est
préoccupante et alarmante parce que si
on fait pas quelque chose si les
pouvoirs publics te rendent pas compte
qu'il faut vraiment
dédier de l'argent sur la recherche sur
ces différentes choses on avancera pas
en fait et ça devient très très complexe
alors le thème de cette année c'est
changing perspective change les
perspectives changeons les regards en
français on entend souvent des
stéréotypes du genre il est obèse parce
qu'il mange mal ou parce qu'il fait pas
assez de sport cette journée elle sert
aussi à ça à casser ses préjugés donc il
y aura effectivement à l'Institut
Montsouris 4 conférences qui vont être
autour de ça donc la première table
ronde sera sur le dépistage comment on
se fait disputer il y aura le deuxième
tableau ronde justement tout un focus
c'est quoi la grossophobie donc il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont sortis
actuellement sur la grossophobie ensuite
les parcours de soins commencent prend
en charge et pour finir et ben quelles
sont les perspectives d'avenir justement
chirurgie ou pas comment on accompagne
les patients vers quelle direction on
les envoie
Régine vous avez une question oui
justement vous disiez que l'obésité
pouvait être pouvait être
multifactorielle que justement on a ce
préjugé de dire c'est parce qu'on mange
mal qu'on est obèse et à votre avis quel
serait les autres facteurs comment
est-ce que ça explique il y a
l'endocrinologie il y a tout ce qui est
l'environnement il y a effectivement le
manger facile le manger non sain le
manger rapide mais il y a des effets
psychologiques il y a des quand on
interroge et quand on échange avec des
personnes qui sont en situation
d'obésité on se dit ouh là c'est
compliqué ils ont des passifs très
lourds surtout dans l'adolescence et
pour ça que des discriminations des
regards
on se construit une carapace
effectivement pour se protéger de tout
ça et c'est compliqué et
il y a pas que la diététique et
malheureusement pas que l'activité
physique effectivement bah le fait aussi
qui a des jeux vidéo ces films et tout
ça ça va pas ranger on va rester en
sédentarité on va rester sur son canapé
mais l'objectif c'est effectivement de
d'aider des adolescents à se mettre en
activité et ça a été aussi une une un
champ de direction pour notre journée
nous avons développé une application
pour mettre en marche justement plein de
personnes autour de cette journée qui a
démarré depuis le 18 février c'est
l'application JMO le défi des jumeaux
voilà voilà qu'on a appelé comme ça
parce que je trouvais que c'était le
principe de cette application
et on marche par centre on est soit
rattaché à centre médical ou pas
l'objectif c'est effectivement celui qui
réalise le plus grand nombre de pas et
donc il y aura un gagnant homme et femme
il y aura deux gagnants en fait et après
il y aura un gagnant au niveau des
centres hospitaliers qui auront
effectivement
aider à mettre les gens en marche alors
angélique la fin de l'association foie
plume France travaille avec des centres
spécialisés comme celui de l'hôpital de
Rambouillet qu'est-ce qui est fait sur
place concrètement alors concrètement
nous on organise des groupes de travail
et de paroles donc en lien avec
l'association poids plumes qui sont des
en fait des retours de patients experts
donc c'est très important au niveau de
la prise en charge de l'obésité voilà on
travaille en nous on a monté donc ce
service de chirurgie bariatrique en 2020
et donc du coup on a très rapidement on
bien donc avec l'association poids
plumes et effectivement donc on a un
passeport de de prise en charge qui
accompagne le patient tout au long de
son parcours donc ce soit médical ou
chirurgical et dedans nous avons du coup
le plaquettes de l'association poids
plume pour voilà leur donner des petites
clés des savoir où s'adresser pas qu'en
interne mais aussi au niveau associatif
et alors pour la Journée mondiale de
l'obésité qui aura lieu samedi quel est
quel est le problème quel est le
programme à l'hôpital de Rambouillet
alors un super programme
donc bon nous c'est la première année
qu'on participe donc à cette journée
mondiale de l'obésité donc en
coordination donc avec l'association
poids plume on a aussi la GMR que
l'association gym de marche de
Rambouillet qui voilà a participé
activement aussi du coup à l'application
des filles JMO et si on est en lien avec
le centre spécialisé de l'obésité
Île-de-France ouest et donc nous avons
un programme ou le matin on va
retransmettre donc les conférences qui
auront lieu un institut Montsouris avec
un petit voilà un petit accueil et
l'après-midi nous avons mis en place des
ateliers donc un premier atelier donc
quiz sur la diététique très ludique on a
essayé de casser les codes pour que ce
soit rigolo et que les gens s'amusent
aussi tout en passant des messages pour
sensibiliser les gens et aussi comme
disait Claudine voilà qui a démontré un
peu les codes casser les codes certains
codes donc voilà je vous en dirai pas
plus il faut que les gens viennent et
ils y participent après aussi on aura
une période où il y a des stands où en
fait on a nos professionnels de santé
donc les médecins donc les chirurgiens
l'endocrinologue la psychologue la
diététicienne et voilà tous les
intervenants qui seront sur place aussi
l'association hgmr qui va venir aussi
parce que nous on a un partenariat avec
eux justement dans notre service de
chirurgie bariatrique pour essayer de
stimuler les gens aussi à aller marcher
et que c'est pas parce qu'on est en
surpoids qu'on ne peut pas aller faire
de la Ran voilà donc il y a des choses
qui sont adaptées du coup à nos patients
et voilà donc et après aussi on a un
atelier plein de conscience avec Nolwenn
notre psychologue qui du coup sur tout
pour la l'atelier immersif pour prendre
conscience de son corps et de voir un
petit peu où on se situe et puis on
terminera par du yoga si si c'est
possible voilà vraiment
pluridisciplinaire en fait
on a fait examen aussi un film sur les
deux parcours sur le parcours médical et
le parcours chirurgical pour présenter
l'équipe et rassurer les patients ok
merci beaucoup à toutes les deux pour
d'être venu d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau un dernier mot
peut-être qu'est-ce qui ferait de cette
journée une journée réussie selon vous
qu'on comprenne que c'est déjà une
maladie et qu'on arrête de congom ces
idées reçues que c'est on ne marchant
pas et en mangeant mal que on est on
devient
une personne en situation d'obésité et
juste pour vous dire aussi que ça sera
retransmis sur tous les réseaux sociaux
on n'a pas dit et que
et que ben on attend beaucoup de monde
voilà ça sera ça voilà ça sera ça notre
réussite et bien merci beaucoup Claudine
cannelle angélique la fondament accepté
notre invitation je le rappelle du coup
le samedi 4 mars c'est la journée
mondiale de l'obésité des conférences
des ateliers et des animations seront
organisées par l'association poids
plumes France durant la journée
notamment à Paris et à l'hôpital de
Rambouillet une triste nouvelle à
présent l'ancien président de Radio
France rôles en force était un ce samedi
à l'âge de 96 ans un homme des médias
qu'a connu l'ancien maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et aujourd'hui le
sénateur Michel Laugier ancien
journaliste il a travaillé avec Roland
fort aux nouvelles de Versailles et
aussi sur la radio canal Versailles
stéréo plus connue sous le nom de DVS il
se souvient de son professionnalisme on
l'écoute vous êtes en radio il faut que
tout soit prêt au moment où vous êtes en
direct voilà donc là il y a pas il y a
pas de amateurisme possible donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai appris avec lui
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de rigueur
et surtout c'était
quelqu'un qui connaissait parfaitement
le monde politique et c'est vrai que
j'ai eu la chance dans le quand je
choisis le journal sur CVS mais d'être
aussi au contact des grands hommes
politiques du moment
on en parlait en début d'émission le
parc animalier de Thoiry créé en 1968 va
investir plus de 30 millions d'euros
pour réaliser des travaux d'ampleur il
va notamment développer son offre
d'hébergement avec des Loges l'objectif
booster sa fréquentation et atteindre
plus d'un million de visiteurs d'ici
2023 notre journaliste Mickaël elmidoro
a rencontré la présidente du groupe de
Thoiry nous sommes à Thoiry Thoiry qui
va investir 30 millions d'euros d'ici
2028 pour créer plusieurs projets nous
sommes avec Christelle la PDG du groupe
Thoiry alors Christelle pourquoi 30
millions d'euros à quoi ça va servir
d'euros ça va servir à beaucoup de
choses aujourd'hui on a un parc qui a 50
ans et qui va verser 60 ans en 2028 donc
symboliquement depuis 2022 nous avons
entrepris d'investir aussi bien pour
rénover le parc à pied et la réserve et
redonner ses lettres de noblesse à la
réserve aussi bien dans développer des
largement renouveler l'aventure aussi
vous allez pouvoir le voir d'ici déjà le
printemps 2023 où les aires de jeux
enfants le safari Arpa fond peau neuve
et puis vous avez juste là les tanières
qui ont ouvert depuis 2021 qui a été la
première pierre de ce projet hébergement
qui est lié à l'animal il y a l'animal
mais on respectant l'animal puisque on a
à cœur de plutôt contraindre l'espace
humain c'est vraiment le l'objectif et
c'était vraiment le l'ADN du projet
tanière qui est fait à 60 km ce sont des
Open bed on appelle ça l'Open Bay entre
la Bâtie de la cabine de bateau aussi
bien la palombière inspirée pour
l'observation de voir sans être vu et
vous passez la nuit ici à écouter en
immersion totale au cœur de la réserve
américaine avec les bisons avec les
loups les coyotes les petits oursons on
espère puisque on se peut qu'il y en ait
qui arrive au printemps il fait encore
un peu frais donc on les a pas encore vu
mais on sait qu'il y en a quelques-uns
dans les tanières donc effectivement
c'est vraiment ce concept là et puis
c'est rythmé jusqu'en 2028 puisque nous
avons 2024 l'année prochaine la deuxième
phase tanière avec un hébergement plus
costume qui sera avec la thématique loup
arctique juste de l'autre côté de la
butte on ira voir ce qui est en train de
se créer pour l'instant et puis déjà des
idées septembre 2023 les hébergements
qui seront liés avec les éléphants
puisqu'on a recréé une nouvelle zone
complètement nouvelle de trois hectares
pour nos deux éléphants actuellement et
en troisième qui va arriver au printemps
il y a vous qui vient de Suède et qui a
10 ans également comme oyo qui est
arrivé avec nous en septembre-octobre
l'année dernière et puis 2025 ce sera un
grand projet sur une vingtaine
d'hectares qui sont encore un petit peu
plus loin de l'autre côté donc sont que
des terres inexploitées qui sera le
mieux autour de terres sauvages et donc
de grands espaces préservés à des
troupeaux des grands herbivores pour
pouvoir justement plutôt enterré les
lodge et les faire disparaître dans le
paysage et pouvoir accueillir un maximum
de personnes dans tout le confort l'idée
aujourd'hui avec tout ce qu'on a mis en
place c'est la le développement du parc
c'est plus une excursion mais une vraie
destination et qu'on peut passer deux
jours pour faire la visite du parc et la
visite des infrastructures et vive les
aventures c'était une demande ou pas de
la part des clients alors de plus en
plus souvent on nous posait la question
là d'hébergement puisqu'il y en a
d'autres qui existent dans les parcs on
n'a pas été on n'est pas les premiers
mais malgré tout on note positionnement
à nous et vraiment sur le côté où on
offre un maximum d'espace aux animaux et
on essaie de contraindre l'humain on
reste dans l'ADN de 1968 qui avait été
créé par Paul delapanouze ou ont
vraiment on a appris à contrepiens un
peu tout et ouvert le terrain mis en mi
permis par nous parmi aux gens qui sont
dans leur voiture eux-mêmes enfermés
dans la voiture de faire la visite oui
l'idée c'est pas forcément d'être comme
dans certains eaux spectateurs là on est
quasiment acteurs finalement de de sa
soirée de son week-end alors là sur le
Tania principalement effectivement vous
grillez vous-même votre dîner vous êtes
acteur vous devez participer avec le
Rangers toute la soirée à observer les
animaux vous avez une visite aussi en
mode VIP tout seul dans le parc et le
matin vous pouvez vous allez prendre le
camion brousse pour faire le réveil de
la réserve et voir les premières sorties
d'animaux toute la tout au long de la
tout au long de la saison 30 millions
d'euros c'est le plus gros
investissement peut-être qu'a fait
Thoiry dans son histoire alors 30
millions d'euros oui effectivement sur
une période aussi courte parce qu'on
parle de 6 ans parce que ça a commencé
en 2022 c'est assez c'est assez
conséquent évidemment pour pouvoir
justement pérenniser aussi l'activité en
60 ans il faut renouveler il faut y
aller et puis du coup c'est vraiment
pour pouvoir imaginer c'est un million
de visiteurs en 2028 puisque aujourd'hui
on est à 640000 visiteurs donc avec de
gros enjeux aussi et puis il y a aussi
toute la mutation de la réserve en 68 on
avait des voitures qui se sont rentrés
mais comme comme on avait une voiture
pour 3 à 4 familles on se réunissait
dedans et on faisait la visite et bien
en 2020 depuis quelques temps on voit
bien qu'il y a beaucoup de voitures par
famille et que le modèle que l'on nous
avions arrive un petit peu à sa fin et
donc on est en train de travailler sur
ce qu'on appelle la circulation douce
pour pouvoir offrir plusieurs façons de
faire la réserve pour offrir aussi une
vraie expérience de façon à ce que les
clients puissent retrouver cette liberté
à l'intérieur de la réserve et à la fois
pouvoir voir différents points de vision
et différentes vues de la Réserve
africaine et donc on est en train de
travailler sur des véhicules des
véhicules électriques ou les véhicules à
l'énergie propre aussi bien commun comme
nos camions rousses qui vont passer
rapidement en énergie propre puisque
aujourd'hui c'est de l'essence demain ça
peut être du gaz ça peut être aussi bien
de l'électrique on est en train de
travailler sur le sujet c'est aussi de
connecter le parc à pied et la réserve
avec des systèmes de passerelles
suspendus pour pouvoir justement entrer
vers les grands herbivores à pied avec
c'est l'énergie la plus propre l'énergie
humaine malgré tout et puis on travaille
sur un un petit prototype un petit
véhicule qui nous permettrait de visiter
à 360 degrés la réserve à pouvoir
justement présenter cela normalement en
septembre 2023 un petit zinglement
se transforme pas parce qu'on garde
l'ADN c'est l'ADN historique l'adnature
vous voyez dans Thoiry il y a peu de
scénarisation artificielle on travaille
en circuit court avec tout simplement le
bois qui tombe le bois qui est qui sert
aussi pour les décorations pour laisser
nos graphiques et histoires granditoires
et avance et Thoiry se réinventent
quotidiennement c'est la base de toi et
les innovations qui ont déjà été faites
les tunnels les points de vision en
passerelle ou en tunnel en dessous au
dessus au dessus l'animal c'est l'ADN de
Thomas c'est Lodge que vous allez créer
comment vous allez sélectionner les
animaux alors les animaux sont pas
sélectionnés à proprement dit on
travaille avec des coordinateurs au
niveau européen et en fonction des
espèces on a l'autorisation ou pas de de
faire des naissances par exemple les
lois arctiques qui vont être de ce côté
là pour le printemps avec les tanières
sont les lois qui sont nés ici nous
avions un couple de l'eau arctique
l'année dernière quatre bébés sont nés
donc ça fait une meute et donc pour
préserver l'écosystème de une réserve
américaine cette mode va être séparée de
cette réserve là pour pouvoir justement
lui offrir une nouvelle espace qui a
complètement de l'autre côté et pour
pouvoir continuer à vivre et grandir et
puis ici il y a des loups gris qui vont
arriver pour le printemps de façon à
recréer une meute et au fur et à mesure
que ne que les que les meutres ou que
les nos animaux se développent ou se
reproduisent et bien on crée de nouveaux
espaces pour eux ou tout simplement
suivant les programmes puisque les
programmes sont portés par l'Europe mais
ils sont envoyés pour d'autres
reproductions à notre à dans d'autres
parcs animaliers et évidemment le Saint
Graal c'est le pouvoir de les relâcher
dans la nature si c'est possible on va
maintenant aller voir les autres animaux
et les nouveautés qu'il y aura cette
année 2023 à Thoiry on y va allez
[Musique]
alors Christelle on a vu le projet
d'agrandissement ici aux autoris
jusqu'en 2028 maintenant on est dans le
parc alors quels seront les nouveautés
en 2023 à découvrir ici et ben le parc
c'est bon aussi sur la partie aventure
avec les aires de jeux l'île mystérieux
ce qui s'est renouvelle complètement et
qui va être couverte pour Pâques le
Safari qui va offrir un nouveau parcours
au dessus des animaux et de la Réserve
africaine et puis beaucoup de naissances
à l'unescence qui arrive au fur et à
mesure de l'année
fourmilier géant et puis si petit bébé
caille mon main crocodile et donc
vraiment c'est des choses un peu rares
qu'on est très contents et le petit
fourmilia vient de passer ses premières
journées à l'extérieur avec un beau
soleil ça promet on peut tout faire ici
en une journée à Thoiry où c'est un peu
compliqué maintenant et maintenant ça
commence à fougourir un petit peu sur la
journée si on veut tout faire avec aussi
bien les lumières sauvages en ce moment
qui finissent dans 15 jours que la
partie animale ou que la partie aventure
qui est relou avec les sols le soleil
bah il faut plus d'une journée c'est
pour ça qu'il y a le pass annuel et puis
il y a le billet de jour maintenant
merci Christelle moi je vais continuer
un petit peu à la visite vous l'aurez
compris jusqu'en 2028 il y aura 30
millions d'euros qui seront investis ici
à toi et comme chaque mercredi
maintenant nous partons à la découverte
d'une école ou d'une formation dans les
Yvelines Régina allège ce soir vous
allez nous parler du centre de formation
des métiers du bâtiment et des travaux
publics de qui se situe à Trappes tout à
fait Mathilde cette semaine on part à la
découverte des métiers du bâtiment et
c'est une branche dont on parle peu et
qui pourtant recrute énormément alors en
quelques mots le CFM BTP c'est un CFA
donc un centre de formation d'apprenti
il a été créé en 1976 dans la ville
d'orsement dans les Yvelines et ce
spécialise comme son nom l'indique dans
les métiers du bâtiment et des travaux
publics alors vous propose plusieurs
niveaux de diplôme on a le titre
professionnel le cap le BP et le BTS en
ce qui concerne les filières dont on a
la filière du bâtiment et la filière des
travaux publics les bâtiments donc ça va
être la construction de maison
d'appartement de d'édifice et en ce qui
concerne le les travaux publics alors
les travaux publics faut savoir que
c'est plutôt des chantiers qui sont
commandés par les pouvoirs publics ou
des grandes entreprises comme par
exemple Vinci ou héifage et donc du coup
on va plutôt parler de travaux routiers
par exemple ou de réseaux de
canalisations et quel métier peut-on
faire suite à ces formations régimes
alors c'est très varié on peut parler de
maçon on peut aussi devenir peintre ou
être étancheur donc c'est un métier que
je ne connaissais pas du tout donc le
métier d'étancheur qui consiste
justement à mettre en place en tout cas
à vérifier l'étanchéité dans l'ouvrage
pour éviter justement tout ce qui est
infiltration de d'humidité d'eau et donc
pour en parler avec nous Julien Guillerm
alors vous êtes étudiant en deuxième
année de bts quel est le parcours que
vous avez suivi
moi j'ai commencé par un cap Masson qui
est une formation sur deux ans où j'ai
appris le à monter du bloc à brancher
construire un voile et j'ai poursuivi
après sur un bac pro TBO qui déjà
s'oriente un peu plus sur de la gestion
de chantier mais qui reste quand même un
peu plus terrain pratique et là je suis
actuellement en BTS bâtiment qui est là
du coup complètement de la direction de
chantier en tout cas pour le poste que
j'occupe
et donc aujourd'hui
on alternant chez bouygues Bâtiment à
Guyancourt ce que vous pouvez vous nous
raconter un peu vos missions en
alternance alors l'émission au sein de
Bouygues sont assez variés moi je
m'occupe un poste d'assistant chef de
chantier donc ça va être principalement
de la gestion d'équipe de la gestion de
chantier ça va être du traçage regardez
si les équipes ne manquent de rien
prévoir d'éventuels commandes et pouvoir
interagir aussi avec les différents
fournisseurs et les différents clients
est-ce que c'est difficile de trouver
une alternance justement dans ce secteur
c'est un métier qui recrute énormément
après qui est à mon sens c'est
l'alternance dans le bâtiment est pas
encore assez connu au sein des
entreprises qui est un peu dommage
mais
c'est on va dire un métier qui
permet de recruter par la suite et
du centre de formation des métiers du
BTP
filière bâtiment par exemple en BTS là
on a des cours qui s'orientent via un
milieu qui veut être scientifique on a
de la mécanique on va nous apprendre
ajustement expliquer comprendre le
support d'une charge affection ça
résistance au béton ou à la ferraille
aux différentes intempéries et on a
aussi des cours on nous apprend à
nous exprimer à avoir une éloquence et
toujours des des cours
théoriques sur l'installation de
chantier de la gestion de chantier et de
la gestion d'équipe comment est-ce qu'on
centre de formation c'est via parcoursup
alors on peut l'intégrer via parcoursup
directement sur la plateforme en
cherchant CFM BTP moi pour ma part étant
déjà sur dans l'établissement c'était
plus une formalité
de continuation et si vous deviez donner
un conseil à un lycéen ou un étudiant en
réorientation qui aimerait rentrer dans
cette école vous lui diriez quoi
de pas avoir peur et de foncer
honnêtement c'est une formation qui est
qui est riche en apprentissage et qui
permet aussi pour les jeunes ce qui est
pas négligeable d'obtenir un salaire du
coup vu que c'est de l'alternance et de
se former un métier en même temps qui
est à mon sens déjà un gros avantage le
jour de la gauche par rapport à
l'employeur qui préférera choisir
quelqu'un qui a justement une filière
apprentissage et justement aujourd'hui
on voit que c'est très varié en termes
de métier est-ce que vous avez déjà une
idée de ce que vous souhaitez faire à la
sortie de vos études
pour le moment je m'occupe du coup un
poste d'assistant chef de chantier dans
l'idée ça serait de d'être embauché en
CDI avec ma société dans ce poste là et
après évoluer en tant que chef de
chantier à dire les échelons et c'est
justement un secteur je pense d'avenir
est-ce que comment comment est-ce qu'on
peut amener justement les étudiants à
s'intéresser à cette filière puisqu'on
parle beaucoup de rénovation énergétique
il y a beaucoup de choses à faire je
pense dans les années à venir est-ce que
à votre avis les étudiants aujourd'hui
sont au courant de tous ces enjeux
comment est-ce qu'on peut les amener
justement à s'intéresser à ces métiers
à mon sens ça serait peut-être important
de faire des journées portes ouvertes
nous en tout cas dans ma société on en
organise avec des écoles où on a des
futurs potentiels apprentis qui viennent
visiter les chantiers on leur explique
un peu le métier et les tâches que en
tant qu'apprenti on réalise et les
tâches que du coup nos supérieurs
embauchés réalisent et
voilà pour moi ça serait pas mal de
diversifier un peu ce côté là pour
apporter un support on va dire visuel en
plus du de ce qu'on peut raconter
sur les formations
j'imagine que les écoles aussi donc font
beaucoup de portes ouvertes parce que je
pense qu'elles sont au courant qu'il y a
une pénurie en tout cas dans le
recrutement est-ce que pour vous comment
si vous devriez vendre cfmbtp quel
serait son point fort selon vous quel
est son point fort
pour moi son point fort en tout cas ce
qui m'a plu
dans ce CFA c'est que ces diversifié au
niveau de la déformation qu'on peut
avoir ça va du CAP au BTS et on peut
avoir une continuité de filière comme
moi je suis resté dans le gros homme en
commençant par un cap Masson en faisant
un bac et un BTS qui est la continuité
justement du gros œuvre donc je pense
que le point fort c'est justement cette
diversification des diplômes et bien
merci beaucoup Julien Guillaume d'être
venu parler de votre de votre école en
plateau allez c'est l'heure maintenant
de passer à notre page cinéma
et on commence cette page cinéma avec
vous Céline Charles alors comme tous les
mercredis on fait le point sur les
sorties ciné de cette semaine le premier
film que vous nous proposez ce soir
c'est le nouveau Creed et oui Mathilde
c'est le troisième volet de la saga
Creed issue de la franchise des Rocky
créé à l'époque par le grand Silvester
Stallone dans ce nouvel opus on retrouve
Michael Bill Jordan devant et derrière
la caméra cette fois-ci c'est le passé
qui s'invite dans la vie du protagoniste
qu'il incarne à Denise Creed regardez
Damien était comme mon frère
[Musique]
on peut même plus parler faut peut-être
que ça se joue sur le rythme
en ce moment maintenant
alors ce frère de cœur dont parle Adonis
c'est Damien alors qu'annony c'est
désormais devenu un père de famille
comblé retraité des rings mais
promoteurs de match cet ami d'enfance
pas très recommandable mais prodiges de
la boxe refait surface Damien lui a tout
appris à l'époque et se retrouve libéré
de prison après plusieurs années si au
début les retrouvailles semblent bien se
passer les tensions ne tardent pas à
arriver ça me donne envie d'aller le
voir en tout cas Céline on continue avec
un tout autre genre vous allez nous
parler d'Empire of light alors tout à
fait Mathilde on parle beaucoup de films
sur le cinéma en ce moment après
Babylone en janvier dernier the Fabel
Mans la semaine dernière c'est
maintenant sam Mendes le réalisateur de
1917 et Skyfall qui s'attaque maintenant
à ce sujet dans Empire of light le film
raconte la vie d'un ancien cinéma dans
une station balnéaire du sud de
l'Angleterre et surtout il parle de
l'histoire d'amour entre Hillary la
responsable du cinéma qui tente de
préserver sa santé mentale fragile et
Stéphane le petit nouveau de l'équipe
Empire of light à Bordeaux des
problématique comme la santé mentale le
racisme ou la crise des cinémas le
réalisateur c'est notamment inspiré de
sa propre enfance et pour terminer
Céline vous nous proposer une comédie
française tout à fait il s'agit du film
Les petites victoires de Mélanie offrait
on y retrouve Jules à Piaton dans le
rôle d'Alice une mairesse et maîtresse
d'école d'un petit village de 400
habitants en Bretagne à lui souhaite le
sauver de la désertification dans son
combat elle croise Émile interprété par
Michel Blanc un sexagénaire au caractère
bien trempé qui souhaite apprendre à
lire regarder qu'est-ce que vous faites
là je vais apprendre
pourquoi tu sais pas lire c'est jamais
rentré dans ma tête et puis après j'ai
oublié
ton crayon bouffon et toi tu es moche
comme ton père
et voilà comme on peut le voir c'est un
feel good movie qui aborde avec
tendresse et humour les enjeux des
petites communes de France ça a l'air de
en tout cas comme d'habitude petit tour
de plateau est-ce que il y a un film que
vous avez préféré parmi la sélection
régime moi je serais bien m'intéresser
par empailleur en live et vous Julien
pas trop de d'avis moi je pense que
j'irai voir Creed au cinéma moi j'irai
voir les petites victoires comme ça
chacun son film on poursuit cette page
cinéma avec le coup de coeur d'un
professionnel du septième art ce soir
c'est le réalisateur yvelinois Benjamin
pallier qui nous partage son coup de
coeur pour le film La vie est belle
regardez
[Musique]
le film dont je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui est un film italien qui
s'appelle la vie est belle et qui a été
réalisé en 1997 par Roberto Benigni
alors ce film est un film où il y a
beaucoup d'émotions moi je suis
quelqu'un qui n'est pas trop émotif
habituellement mais à chaque fois que je
regarde ça me donne les larmes aux yeux
alors pour raconter un peu l'histoire du
film ça se passe pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale en Italie et c'est
l'histoire d'un père et de son fils qui
vont se voir déporter dans un camp de
concentration et tout au long du film le
père va faire croire à son fils que
c'est un jeu qui a des différentes
épreuves et qui a une récompense à la
fin tout ça pour lui mentir et bien sûr
qu'il ne s'aperçoivent pas de la de la
véracité des faits
[Musique]
donc c'est un film qui a rencontré un
grand succès lors de sa sortie en salle
car il a par la suite obtenu différents
prix notamment un Oscar trois Césars et
un prix du Jury à Cannes c'est un film
que je vous conseille vraiment de
regarder il y a une scène qui est
vraiment touchante vers la fin du film
c'est quand le papa se fait arrêter par
un soldat allemand dans le camp de
concentration
et son fils lui est caché et le voit et
jusqu'au bout le père cache l'effet et
il fait semblant de enfin il fait
l’imbécile pour que son fils ne
s'inquiète pas voilà donc allez le voir
c'est vraiment très intéressant comme
film
[Musique]
voilà donc le coup de coeur signé de
Benjamin à palais qui nous replonge dans
nos classiques c'est un film qui a l'air
assez émouvant est-ce que vous l'avez vu
Céline Régine je l'ai pas vu mais j'en
ai beaucoup entendu parler alors je
devrais peut-être m'y mettre bref c'est
un film très touchant je pense qu'il y a
très bien vieilli aussi c'est un
incontournable moi je pleure à chaque
fois chaque fois que je le vois ça a
l'air très émouvant effectivement c'est
bientôt la fin de cette émission mais
juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'œil à
la météo de demain
matin le soleil sera encore au
rendez-vous sur l'ensemble des Yvelines
au niveau des températures il fera
toujours très froid compter 0° à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et
Rambouillet et moins 1 degré à Houdan
alors couvrez-vous bien dans
l'après-midi le ciel sera toujours bien
dégagé avec un beau soleil côté
température comptez 8 degrés du côté de
Houdan et Versailles et 9 degrés dans
les secteurs de Mantes-la-Jolie et
Rambouillet et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous le rappelle demain c'est la Saint
Charles je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]